The right answer is modula -3 pointers
are type-specific. That is, pointers in modula-3
cannot be forged, there's no way to
subvert the protection mechanism that is built into
the language. So if I have a data structure defined In Modula-3. And if
I have pointer to the data structure, the only way you can use that pointer,
is as a pointer to that type of data structure. You cannot take a data structure
and cast it to appear like something else, this is something that we as C
programmers, maybe very used to doing, but
that's not something that is possible in Modula-3.
And that is what allows us to implement
logical protection domains in Modula-3 Using objects and
capabilities to objects as pointers supported by the programming language.